Give ear to my words, O Lord, consider my groaning.
Give attention to the sound of my cry, my king and my God,
for to you do I pray.
O Lord, in the morning you hear my voice.
In the morning I prepare a sacrifice for you and watch.
For you are not a God who delights in wickedness.
Evil may not dwell with you.
The boastful shall not stand before your eyes.
You hate all evil doers.
You destroy those who speak lies.
The Lord appores the bloodthirsty and deceitful man.
But I, through the abundance of your steadfast love,
will enter your house.
I will bow down toward your holy temple in the fear of you.
Lead me, O Lord, in your righteousness,
because of my enemies.
Make your way straight before me.
For there is no truth in their mouth.
Their inmost self is destruction.
Their throat is an open grave.
They flatter with their tongue.
Make them bear their guilt, O God.
Let them fall by their own counsels
because of the abundance of their transgressions,
cast them out, for they have rebelled against you.
But let all who take refuge in you rejoice.
Let them ever sing for joy and spread your protection
over them that those who love your name may exalt in you.
For you bless the righteous, O Lord.
You cover him with favor as with a shield.
This is the word of the Lord.
Thanks be to God.
Thank you, Ali.
Well, what we just read in Psalm five,
some of the very same themes are expressed
in the Lord's Prayer.
So we typically pray before we come
to the preaching of God's words.
I'd like for us to pray the very words
of the Lord's Prayer this morning.
So let's pray together.
Our Father who art in heaven, hallowed be thy name.
Thy kingdom come.
Thy will be done on earth as it is in heaven.
Give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against us.
And lead us not into temptation, but deliver us from evil.
For thine is the kingdom, the power, and the glory
forever and ever.
Amen.
Or down a few in number this morning.
So you felt a bit far away.
So I thought I'd get a bit closer to you.
So I'm gonna speak from about here if that is okay.
So we're looking together at Psalm five.
And really the kind of theme is,
I mean, if you've got an ESV Bible in front of you,
it may have a title which is lead me in your righteousness.
I've just kind of taken that as a theme for today
because it really does draw the whole of the Psalm
together as it prays for direction.
One thing I've forgotten to be thankful about really
in recent years is Google Maps.
I remember years ago, like in the early days of marriage,
like some of our most tense exchanges, if you will,
had to do with directions.
It was in the days of MapQuest.
I don't know if any of you ever used MapQuest,
but you have to print off all the directions
and you print off 20 pages
and you'd get to like page six
and you'd take a wrong turn or something.
And then you're completely thrown off
and you don't know where you are
and you're arguing back and forth.
So it was not a great situation,
but we should be thankful though.
I mean, it was also the early days of GPS
which that could lead you in an even more dangerous
situation, people driving into rivers
or on railroad tracks or off cliffs
as we figured that out.
We need direction.
And we certainly need direction
when it comes to the whole of life.
And roads are probably the easiest thing to navigate.
We need to be guided in all kinds of ways.
And so Psalm five points us to the most reliable guide.
So let's read verse eight again.
It says, lead me, oh Lord, in your righteousness
because of my enemies.
Make your way straight before me.
So David's praying for guidance.
Notice the type of guidance he's praying for here.
He's not praying about what he should do for the future
like in terms of like vocation or where to go to school
you know that kind of thing.
The Lord guides us in those things
and it's good for us to consider that together
and another time we will look into that.
But here, David is praying for a type of guidance
that's even more crucial.
It's a prayer that he would be guided in righteousness.
It's a prayer that God would show him his ways.
It's literally what we just prayed in the Lord's prayer.
Lead us not into temptation but deliver us from evil.
To put it positively it would be lead us
in your righteousness.
So Lord show me your ways is what Moses prayed
that I may know you.
So whatever decisions we make about other areas of life
as we pray for guidance in those things
we need to recognize this is what is most important.
Knowing the righteousness of God
and as we walk in his righteousness
we can be sure that he will guide us
in every area of life.
So I'm just gonna draw your attention to three things
from this Psalm that we need to know
if we're going to follow after this path of righteousness
that is laid before us.
So as we pray, lead me in your righteousness.
We need to know that this is also something
we're praying that we would submit to the reign of God.
So that's the first thing, submit to the reign of God.
So all day long, David is being referred to
by the people around him as King.
He is King David.
But when he prays he recognizes that there is a King
that is higher than him.
So he prays in verse two.
He calls the Lord my King and my God.
Give attention to the sound of my crime,
my King and my God.
So he speaks about the kingship of God.
So calling God King is a recognition
of his absolute authority.
He is the sovereign King.
There's a rich tradition of hymns
where it literally refers to God as our God and King
just like David has here.
So sometimes here we sing all creatures of our God and King.
That's coming right from scripture.
So even in the Lord's prayer, we prayed our Father in heaven.
So when we say in heaven, what are we actually saying
when we say our Father in heaven?
When we kind of think about the Father part
but not necessarily the in heaven part,
we're recognizing the authority of God.
He reigns.
That's what we're saying when we're saying
our God in heaven.
Therefore it follows, we then pray,
hallowed be your name.
In other words, be recognized for who you truly are.
Well, who is he?
Your kingdom come, your will be done
on earth as it is in heaven.
He's the King who has a kingdom.
He's the King who reigns over all things in heaven
and on earth.
And he's the King whether we like it or not.
You know, to get into politics,
which is I'm sure what you all
we're looking forward to today.
No matter who is president,
no matter it was the right or the left here
and there will always be a yard sign somewhere
that says not my president.
It doesn't matter if it's on the Democrat side
or Republican or whatever,
people have that kind of sentiment
like they're not my president
whether they actually are or not.
That's the sentiment that is here.
So here's the truth I'm saying that points to.
God is King whether or not we recognize him
as the absolute authority.
He is Lord.
I know sometimes we might talk about making him
Lord of your life.
He is Lord.
That includes your life too.
Now the question is whether or not we will bow the knee
and recognize him for who he truly is.
He is the Lord whether we like it or not.
So are we submitting to his his kingship?
So this speaks to not just his kingship
but how we approach him.
Right, so we're submitting to the reign of the King.
So how do we approach him in prayerful submission?
Remember this is a prayer
and this prayer is an invitation to bow our knee
before the Lord as King
and confess in prayer that he is Lord.
You see this as well in what David says next.
He says, oh Lord, in the morning you hear my voice.
In the morning I prepare a sacrifice for you and watch.
When you bring a sacrifice,
you're saying that you no longer have ownership
of the thing you are bringing.
You're giving it over completely in sacrifice.
This is what we do when we rightly pray.
We are bringing our lives before the Lord
in complete surrender.
So Jesus calls his disciples.
So Luke chapter nine verse 23
to take up their cross daily and follow him.
Like surrender your life daily afresh to the Lord.
My life is not my own.
It belongs to you.
All right, so this is a morning psalm.
So David is bringing his prayers to the Lord
in the morning.
So like David it's good to bring our day
and our lives before the Lord each morning
and say your kingdom come, your will be done.
So there's prayerful submission here
but there's also a kind of hopeful expectation.
Notice what he says when he lays down his sacrifice
before the Lord he says he lays it down
and he watches.
He says now I watch.
That's hopeful expectation.
So as we submit to God's reign
we do so in the hopeful expectation
or anticipation that he will do what is right.
He is our Father in heaven.
And so we can know that he is our Father.
He's willing to do what is best
but also as the one in heaven as the King
he is able to bring about all the good
that he promises.
He's the sovereign King who can bring about
all the good he promises in our lives.
So a wonderful passage to go to
which I know many of you will be familiar with
is Romans 828 where Paul speaks
with that kind of assurance.
He says for we know that all things
work together for the good of those who love God
to those who are the called according to his purpose.
Now that doesn't mean all things work together
for good.
It doesn't mean that everything that happens is good
and that doesn't mean just wait a few minutes
and everything is going to all of a sudden resolve
like the stereotypical Christian movie
where the team wins the game at the end
and the coach gets a brand new truck
and everything is just right
because all things work together for the good after all.
The thing is we can't fully grasp the kind of good
that's being spoken of in Romans 828
and let you see Romans 829.
That tells us what good purpose
the Lord is bringing about.
God is bringing about conformity to the likeness of his son.
So what is the good that God is at work
in all things to bring about in our lives?
Conformity to his son is what it says in Romans 829.
In other words, he is at work in all things for our good
in order that we might be led in his righteousness.
So we pray Lord lead me in your righteousness
in all things.
Okay, so we submit to the reign of God
but also secondly, for it's going to be led in his righteousness
we must revere the holiness of God.
Revere the holiness of God.
All right, so context here.
David is groaning before the Lord.
You see that in verse one.
And he's groaning before the Lord as you read it.
This is similar to the Psalms we've just seen.
He's groaning because he's surrounded by enemies.
His life is under threat.
But he recognizes that there is an even greater threat
and even greater danger.
And that greater threat or that greater danger
is following the path that his enemies are taking.
So this is why he's praying Lord lead me
in your righteousness.
You see that in verse eight.
He's saying lead me in your righteousness
because of my enemies.
All right, so he's praying that the Lord in contrast
to the way his enemies are going
would lead him on this straight path.
So another reason we should ask the Lord
to lead us in righteousness is because he is holy
and because sin is deadly.
Let's put it simply.
God is holy, sin is deadly.
We see that here.
You see the holiness of God here in verse four for example.
He says for you are not a God who delights in wickedness.
Evil may not dwell with you.
Or you see in verse seven.
He says, but I through the abundance
of your steadfast love will enter your house.
I will bow down toward your holy temple
in the fear of you.
So when he's approaching God,
he remembers that God's dwelling place is holy.
He is a God of perfect righteousness.
So he's approaching God assured of his love
but he's also approaching God with a fear
or a reverence knowing that God is also holy.
So what does it mean to say that God is holy?
Well, let's just take the descriptions that he gives us.
So verse four.
God is displeased with sin.
He does not delight in wickedness.
So we're tempted to sin.
Why?
Because it's desirable for us.
We want it.
But it's not desirable to God.
Not even for a second.
He doesn't take any pleasure in sin.
But also we see that God will not dwell with evil either.
So his presence, his dwelling place, his a holy place.
Evil may not dwell with you, it says in verse four.
So evil is never at home with God,
not even for a second.
This is why it says in Habakkuk 1.13,
your eyes are too pure to look on evil.
So if that is the holiness of God in relation to sin,
what about people who commit sin?
Let's read verse five again.
Says the boastful shall not stand before your eyes.
You hate all evildoers.
Well, one of the good things,
but hard things about preaching through books
of the Bible like this is it makes us look
at hard truths that are difficult to understand
or truths that make us uncomfortable.
Let me tell you, what I just read is one of those,
at least for me, or you hate all evildoers.
Like I've preached a general series
through the Psalms before
and let me tell you which Psalm I skipped.
It was Psalm five and a few others.
There are 150 Psalms.
So what do we do with a passage like this?
First of all, I mean, know that God doesn't need
our kind of PR support, right?
He doesn't need that from us.
Let me just call us back to that kind of first point
we're seeing about his kingship.
We need to submit to the authority of God.
And how does the king reign?
He reigns, he governs by his word.
So to submit to the authority of God
is to submit to his word, to all of it,
even the parts we may not understand
or that make us uncomfortable.
So we need to sit with what it says here.
And it doesn't just say it here.
It says the same thing in Psalm 11, verse five,
speaks about God as hating sinful people
in Malachi chapter one, verses two and three.
We'll get to some encouraging news in a second
but let's sit with this for a moment.
Because without realizing it,
we can have a distorted view of God
where we like certain verses of the Bible
and that's all that we think about in relation to God
and but we don't see the whole of scripture,
this entire picture of God.
So what does this mean?
God hates all evil doers.
What means, here's the truth,
that God's righteous justice
stands not only against evil but evil doers.
Where you cannot fully separate out
the actions from the person that commits those actions.
If you go to a court for a crime that has been committed
and the judge makes the sentence,
he sentences you, right?
He doesn't say like, oh, you stole this,
so I'm gonna punish your thieving, your theft.
No, you are the one who is punished for the crime.
So it's true that God is against sin
but also here, those who commit sin as well.
He opposes not only sinful behavior
but the very ones who carries out this behavior.
Okay, so God's holy character is seen in his conduct.
So what does it say in verse six?
You destroy all those who speak lies.
The Lord abhor is the bloodthirsty and deceitful man.
We'll return to that in just a moment with some good news.
But notice as well, not just the holiness of God,
he is that pure, that holy.
But also the deadliness of sin.
So we read not only about God's holy character and conduct,
we read the opposite of that.
We read about the conduct and character
of those who oppose God.
So we see all kinds of descriptions
of like people's wickedness or evil
or boastfulness, deceitfulness, violence.
And he returns to this theme in verses nine and 10.
And in verses nine and 10,
there's a particular focus here.
And it's showing that sin is,
when it comes to the deadliness of sin,
it points us particularly to the deceitfulness of sin
and how that deceitfulness is what leads us
to the deadliness of sin.
So in verse nine, we see that they speak
in flattering ways the enemies of David here.
There's no truth in their mouths.
Their words are deceitful.
So I got to start thinking about this
this week, if you were to think about like
there being a stream that sin is then flowing from,
you're to trace sin and all of its impact on humanity.
Right back to the source, what would you find?
Well, you go back to the Garden of Eden
and you would find deceit, you would find a lie there.
So you can take all of sin
and put it in that category of deceit here.
That's what it's all going back to.
And so he then uses kind of graphic imagery here
to describe the deadliness of sin.
So on the front side of things, there's flattery.
There's things that sounds maybe appealing or plausible,
but he wants us to see that it's really deadly.
He says their inmost self, verse nine is destruction.
And their throat is like an open grave.
So what they're saying may seem plausible or desirable,
but it's coming from a place of spiritual death.
It's a demonstration of the fact
that someone is dead spiritually
when they're speaking these falsehoods, these lies.
So we saw in Ephesians two in verse one,
speaks about us being dead in our trespasses and sins.
All right, so things might sound good,
but it's coming from a place of death.
You might think of like, I don't know,
a beautiful place like the Taj Mahal
and you're like, well, what is this place?
It's actually a grave, it's a tomb.
So there's beauty, but death behind it.
Death is ultimately God's judgment upon sin.
It's being separated from life with him.
It is being under his wrath.
And David actually speaks here of God's judgment
in a way that we might not always think of.
Notice what he says in verse 10.
He says, make them bear their guilt of God.
Let them fall by their own counsels.
So here's the judgment that God is giving here.
This is what he's praying for here.
It's a judgment to let them chase after what they want.
Let them follow the path they are already going down.
So it's God's judgment, in other words,
to give people what they are already seeking after
and to see where that actually leads.
It's giving them over to what they were wanting anyway.
So you see this in Romans chapter one,
God giving people over to their passions
and then experiencing the consequences of that.
So scripture speaks of God's judgment in that way,
giving people what they want rather than
the path of righteousness,
the good that he is leading his people in.
But how does this apply to us?
Well, here's what the psalmist is not calling us to do.
Make these big placards of the God hates,
and then whichever people you dislike the most
and kind of go and protest somewhere that you might see,
have a list of your pet peeve sins
and like flames at the bottom, you kind of see that,
that kind of thing.
That's not what he's calling us to do here.
We're actually hit with a big dilemma.
The fact is, we are all indicted by the things
that he says here.
When it comes to the holiness of God and our sinfulness,
I recently heard a child say to his dad,
he said, dad, in a war,
are there always good guys and bad guys?
You know, where it's kind of like one side or the other.
And I thought, well, that is actually a pretty profound
question to ask.
And if we're reading a psalm like this as though,
like, we're the good guys and other people out there
are the bad guys, well, look again.
This is who we all are apart from the mercy of God.
This is what we all deserve.
It's interesting, who wrote this?
David.
Kind of look at this checklist here and you're like,
well, David, deceit.
That sounds like something I've heard of you
in Second Samuel.
Right, so as you're working through these descriptions
of sinfulness, these are descriptions of David,
the very person who's praying these things.
Right, so description that lines up with his own sin.
And when you get to the New Testament,
particularly Romans chapter three,
which speaks about us all being sinful, you know.
Romans 3, 23, all of sin and false short of the glory of God.
It also quotes Psalm five in the description of sinfulness
here to describe the whole of humanity.
Fascinating, I was amazed to see that,
oh, like his Psalm five quoted in the New Testament.
Yes, in Romans three where it says this is all of us.
Amazing.
So if we're going to appreciate the salvation
that God provides for us in Christ,
then we need to know what we have been saved from.
If we are going to truly embrace the good news
and see how good it is and see how good the Lord's way is,
then we need to know the bad news
of the other way that we have been saved from.
Years ago, I remember hearing an evangelist
from New Zealand talking about somebody being offered
a parachute on a flight.
And he said basically like, if you're on a flight
and somebody comes up to you on the stewards
and they give you a parachute and they say,
well, hey, it'd be a good idea to put this on.
And didn't give you much explanation or like,
oh, your flight's gonna be much better if you put this on.
Like you might wear it for a little bit
and you might think, well, this is a bit weird.
I'm actually pretty uncomfortable wearing this parachute.
And after a while, you might just take it off
and leave it behind.
He said, well, then, well, what if that same steward
came over to you and said, just so you know,
I'm really sorry, this flight is going down
in 30 minutes time.
And this parachute here is your only hope.
You're gonna put that parachute on.
Whether you look weird or not,
whether it's uncomfortable or not,
you are going to wear the parachute
because you know the danger you would be in otherwise
without it.
So here's the point.
Some people have heard a gospel that leaves out
the kind of uncomfortable part about God's holiness
in our sin and his judgments.
And they might think, well, they're doing okay.
Like somebody told me God loves me
and has a wonderful plan for my life.
And so I accepted Jesus.
And maybe they wear him a little bit for a while
if I can use that kind of language.
But then when it gets uncomfortable
or if they're looking at other people around them
and they're not so sure
and it'd be easier to just leave it behind.
Now, Jesus does bring more good into our lives
than we can fathom.
And in him we can see that God does love us
and have a good plan for our lives.
But we also need to know that he saves us
from the judgment that we deserve.
Now I hope we are people who are first and foremost
compelled by his beauty.
That's not the only message in scripture.
The message of John the Baptist, for example,
is flee the wrath to come.
And we could look at many places
where that's there in scripture.
Just look at our opening scripture.
There in Romans five.
You see both the love of God and the wrath of God
there in the same place.
God shows, verse eight, his love for us
in that while we were still sinners, Christ died for us.
Since therefore we have been justified by his blood,
much more shall we be saved by him
from the wrath of God.
Now this is the same God being spoken of here.
All right, so we deserve the wrath of God.
But God demonstrates his love toward us,
how, and that while we're still sinners,
while we are sinners, who deserve all of that,
Christ dies for us.
So to be led in the righteousness of God
is to see his holiness and to see our sinfulness.
But it also means therefore then to be led
to the one who loves us and gave himself for us
in order to save us.
So we revere God's holiness
if we're gonna be led in his righteousness.
I love what Jack Miller says.
This kind of summarizes what I'm saying here much better.
He said, cheer up.
You are a worse sinner than you ever dared imagine.
And you are more loved than you ever dared hope.
Right, so both of those things are true.
This is what leads us to the last part then.
This is where I want us to land
and take a breath of fresh air here, all right?
So we need to submit to God's reign.
Yes, he's the one who reigns over all things.
We need to revere his holiness, see his righteousness.
And then we need to take refuge in his love.
Take refuge in his love.
So David's hope here is not grounded
in his own inherent goodness,
as though like he's just better
than the other people he's speaking of.
His hope is grounded in the love of God.
So let's see these wonderful hopeful words here in verse seven.
He says, but I, through the abundance
of your steadfast love will enter your house.
And I will bow down towards your holy temple
in the fear of you.
So he's approaching God because he knows
that God loves him.
Yes, he's approaching God with reverence
because he knows God is holy,
but he's approaching God with confidence
because he knows that God is loving.
And not just that, he's a God of,
I love this word here, abundance, steadfast love.
There's an abundance to the love of God.
So he's confident that he can dwell
in the presence of a holy God.
So how can somebody who's sinful be that confident?
Because he knows that that same God
has set his love upon him.
He's been brought into a loving relationship
with a God who keeps his covenant.
So how can we enter the presence of a holy God?
Because in love God has provided all
that we need to be reconciled to him.
So we run to God and find a home in him
through faith in Christ because it is in Jesus
we see the abundant love of God.
We find a refuge in Jesus.
So it's in Jesus that we come to know the love of God.
By the way, don't hear this and what we're saying here.
We're dealing with some weighty, heavy truths this morning.
I recognize that in a room that's pretty hot as well.
That wasn't by design.
So it's not that on the Old Testament side
you've got this vengeful, wrathful God.
And then on the New Testament side
you've got this loving Jesus who's ready to save us.
Right?
This is the same God we're looking at here.
So it's God demonstrating his love for us
in the coming of Christ.
So in Jesus we are seeing the love of the Father as well.
Okay, so we're seeing the very love of God.
But we see Jesus all the way throughout this Psalm,
all these pointers to him.
So David's thinking about this temple as he prays
but we see in the New Testament
that Jesus is the better temple.
Now evil may not dwell with God yet in Christ.
God came to dwell with us so that in Christ
we might be brought into the very presence of God.
The Psalm speaks about a sacrifice
and Jesus is the sacrifice for sin
that is through his substitutionary death
that we see the love of God
and can enter into his holy presence
and know him as our Father
because he's dealt with our sin fully and finally in Jesus.
Jesus is our righteousness.
We're praying, Lord, lead me in your righteousness.
Well, that points us to Jesus.
So when we pray this,
we're pointed to Jesus who said, I am the way.
We're pointed to the one who became sin for us
that we might become the righteousness of God in him.
So to be led on the path of righteousness
is to be enabled by the Spirit
to both embrace Jesus
and the righteousness we're given in him
but also to then live it out
by the power of his Spirit.
And the Psalmist speaks about the refuge
that he finds in God as well in verse 11
and Jesus is our refuge.
Where can we go that we might know
that we will be saved from the deceitfulness of sin
and all the consequences of sin?
It's in Christ.
He is our refuge.
We are safe in him because he bore the wrath
that we deserved.
And so there is Romans 8-1.
There is there now therefore no condemnation
to those who are in Christ Jesus.
None of the condemnation that we spoke about earlier
will be upon anyone who is in Christ Jesus,
not even for a moment.
So we have a perfect refuge in him.
So where are you going to for refuge?
Some people might run to distraction.
So as long as I keep myself busy or entertained,
I don't have to think about my condition or my sinfulness
or maybe self-justification where we think,
well, I'm not as bad as this other person over here
or maybe my logic then follows.
Well, actually I'm not so sure this is true
where it's actually this deceitfulness of sin
guiding my thoughts, that kind of self-justification.
Maybe for our refuge we try out self-righteousness
and think, well, yeah, the problem is sin
but I just need to try harder to do better
to be a quote unquote good Christian.
And we look to that for refuge
but all of those refuges will crumble, they will not last.
They will not be a comfort to us
and they will not save us in the end.
Only Jesus is our refuge.
Our refuge is the love of God that we know in him.
So run to Jesus, know his salvation
but also rejoice in him.
Verse 11, but let all who take refuge in you rejoice.
Let them ever sing for joy
and spread your protection over them
that those who love your name may exalt in you.
The fact is when you know Jesus as your refuge
you can also know him as your joy.
Like the house of the Lord is a place of singing,
of joyfulness, of exalting in him.
We've been looking at all this danger
but there's beauty and therefore joy to be found
in knowing Jesus as your refuge.
You might think of somebody going scuba diving.
If you've ever been scuba diving before
I've experienced it one time in Northeast Alabama
and Little River and I didn't see much but I enjoyed it.
And so somebody going to explore water
is like we weren't made to be underwater.
We can't breathe under there
and you put on the mask or whatever
and you're sucking in the oxygen.
It's scary for a minute.
So try to breathe it in.
But then finally after you're under there for a while
and you can get used to it.
Like yeah, it's scary but I can breathe now.
It's okay.
And then finally you come to a place
the more you're comfortable
where you can see what surrounds you
and start to actually enjoy the beauty
of what you're seeing there under the water.
So why am I saying this?
So think about the holiness of God
or the wrath of God, things like that.
We think, well how could you ever survive that?
We come to see, well if you're in Christ
and you know the life that is in Him
you're no longer repelled by the holiness of God.
You come to see the beauty of the holiness of God.
The air that we're breathing
is the life that we have in Jesus
and the love that we know in Him.
And so therefore instead of running away from God
we run towards Him.
We see the beauty of His righteousness.
We don't want less of God.
We want more of Him.
We don't wanna run away from God.
We wanna go to Him.
And it's Jesus who gives us that.
So we rejoice in Him.
We enjoy Him.
So this prayer that God will lead us in righteousness
is a prayer of humility.
We're bowing before our King, before our holy God.
It's also a prayer of hope
because we find refuge in Jesus
and we rejoice in Him.
So let's praise, shall we?
So Lord I pray that you would help us to bow the knee
before you as the sovereign King who reigns over all things.
Lord you are holy, holy, holy.
So I pray that when we approach you
that we would approach you with humility
knowing that we could have never approached you
on our own, in our own sinful condition.
But Lord we thank you so much for the hope
and the refuge that we have in Jesus.
Lord we thank you that Lord
that you've shown us your love in Him
and that you bring us to Him and show us
we can have a refuge in Him
and we can know a life in your loving home
and instead of running away from your holiness
Lord we can run to you and know more of the joy
that is given to us in you.
So Lord we thank you that when we come to your throne
the throne of you, our holy God
we can find it to be a throne of grace
where we find help in our time of need.
So Lord I pray that you'd help us to be a people
who know what it is to be saved
and to rejoice in the salvation
provided for us in Jesus.
And Lord I pray that we would be a people
who follow you praying Lord lead us in your righteousness
and as we do that we would rejoice more and more in you.
Pray this in Jesus name, amen.